[Musique]
enfin les enfants
patron je me réjouis ce soir nous allons
faire une bonne partie de cache-cache tu
aimes jouer à cache-cache nounours
j'adore ça patron je connais de bottes
cachette
j'espère qu'en te retrouveras et que tu
ne me feras pas attend trop longtemps
voulons patron 63 mon les chocs et hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop tout haut
bonsoir le petit buzz on s'attendait
alors à quel jeu on joue
moi j'ai eu très peur dit que tu vas pas
faire de la cuisine
non nous allons jouer c'est toi qui vas
chercher non c'est moi c'est non non moi
je préfère vous tâchez la copie mettons
morts
[Applaudissements]
il ya chaillet toc toc toc qui fera pas
manquer euros c'est une petite goutte
d'eau
n'entrez pas madame la pluie votre site
amende lui allait plutôt d'un jardin à
hausser le chef mme le romarin thym
prenait le chemin non les romarins du
colloque impossible
nous nous excusons pas à moi toc toc toc
il peut sur le coeur c'est pas paris
nice non c'est le top
il peut sur blatter toc toc toc
il fait noir kurt est au top du bas des
paupières toc toc toc tu fais des
éclairs toc toc
voici le toner vous avez triché
d'accord pas trop j'arrive et voilà au
lieu de faire une bonne partie de
cache-cache vous traînez et à présent il
est trop tard et vous devez aller vous
coucher
le mois
veut faire du ou de pêche temenos moi
vous voulez vous leur toge koch soit
raisonnable non je te promets qu'on
urgent aura une autre se produit vasco
chaîne annonce que c'est même plus
besoin de leurs dix années la 9e nuit
petit job et tu es fâché non tête à la
lumière oui la jute le 2e tome
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors nounours et cette partie de cache
cache
elle revit patron un l'autre jour moi
qui avais tellement envie d'en faire une
tu la feras nounours j'en suis certain
et vous les enfants ne vous disputez
plus vous voyez on ne joue pas quand on
se dispute sorcerer pas trop bonne nuit
les enfants
allez vite vous couchez lui fait de
pauvres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]